So I want to tell you about a book
today.
The book is called the Gulag
Archipelago.
We ready.
The book is called the Gulag Archipelago
and it's by a Russian author,
Soviet author named Alexandra Soldier
Nixon,
who was in the Gulag archipelago
concentration camp system for a very
long time.
He had a very hard life.
He was on the
Russian front when the Germans invaded
Soviet Union in the early stages of
World War II.
Now Hitler and Stalin had signed a
nonaggression pact.
Um,
and Hitler invaded the Soviet Union
anyway.
And from what I've been able to
understand,
the Soviets had prepared an invasion
force for Europe at that point,
but we're not concerned with having to
defend their territory.
And so they were caught completely
unawares by Hitler's move.
And the conditions on the Russian front
were absolutely dreadful.
And Soldier Nixon was a soldier on the
Russian front,
and
he wrote some letters to one of his
friends,
which were intercepted,
complaining about the lack of
preparation and,
and using bitter dark humor to describe
the situation.
And
the consequences of that was that he was
thrown into a work camp.
The Soviet system relied on work camps.
And so those were large labor camps of
people who were essentially enslaved,
many of whom were worked to death,
often froze to death,
working in conditions that were so
dreadful that they're virtually
unimaginable.
Solzhenitsyn spent a very large number
of years in these camps,
uh,
sometimes in a more privileged camp
because he was an educated man and
sometimes in worst camps.
He also,
uh,
developed cancer,
later and wrote a book about that called
Cancer Ward,
which is a brilliant book.
Um,
so he had a very hard life.
There's just no way around that to be on
the front and then to be in a
concentration camp and then to have
cancer.
That's,
that's pretty rough.
Now he wrote the Gulag archipelago.
He wrote a book called one day in the
life of Ivan Denisovich first that was
published in the early 1960s when there
was a brief thought.
Stalin was pretty much out of the
picture.
By the end of the 1950s.
There's some indication that he was
murdered by
Khrushchev.
Ana Khrushchev became premier of the
Soviet Union afters stolen and there's
some indication perhaps that stellan was
either murdered by Khrushchev and a set
of his cronies or when he was very ill
just before he died,
was not helped at least by,
wasn't provided with any medical
attention because of the intervention of
cruise and his cronies.
Now there's some indication as well at
that point that Stalin who was an
absolute absolutely barbaric in every
possible way you could imagine was
planning to start a third World War and
he was certainly capable of doing such
things because he had already imprisoned
or killed tens of millions of people.
Now just after Stalin died,
there was a bit of a thought in the
Soviet Union with regards to internal
repression.
In the early 1960s Solzhenitsyn
published a book called one day in the
life of Ivan Denisovich,
which was a story about one day in the
life,
his life really inside one of these so
called Gulag archipelago camps.
Now,
he called it the Gulag archipelago
because an archipelago is a chain of
islands.
And so soldier knits enlightened the
work camp system in the Soviet Union,
which was made up of isolated camps
distributed across the entire state.
He likened that to a series of islands
and enhance,
hence the metaphor.
And one day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich was one of the first
publications released in the Soviet
Union that dared make public what had
happened inside these camps,
at least initially.
Now that thought didn't last very long,
but that book had a tremendous effect.
It's a short book.
It's worth reading.
Um,
after that he spent,
he wrote a number of other books,
which are also great.
He's a great literary figure in the same
category,
I would say as tolstoy or Dostoevsky,
which is like really saying something,
you know,
those,
those two are perhaps the greatest
literary figures who ever lived with the
possible exception of Shakespeare.
Um,
he wrote this book called the Gulag
Archipelago,
which is published in three volumes,
each of which has about 700 pages long.
Um,
the first one details the origin of the
oppressive Soviet system,
at least in part under Lenin.
And then it's full fledged
implementation under Stalin and the
deaths of while Sojun.
It's an estimated the deaths in,
in internal repression in the Soviet
Union at something approximating 60
million between 1919 in 1959.
Now that doesn't count the death toll in
the second world war by the way.
Now people have disputed those figures
at,
but there are certainly in the tens of
millions and the low end bounds are
probably 20 million and the high end
bounds or nearer what sole sole
Jeanette's an estimated.
He also estimated that the same kind of
internal repression in Maoist China cost
100 million lives.
And so you can imagine that the genuine
historical figures,
again are to dispute,
but somewhere between 50 and a hundred
million people.
And one of the things that's really
surprising to me and that that I think
is absolutely reprehensible,
absolutely reprehensible,
is the fact that this is not widespread
knowledge among students in the West.
Any of this.
And it's because your education,
your historical education,
if you started to describe it as
appalling,
you would barely scratched the surface.
These were the most important events of
the 20th century and they're barely
covered at all in standard historical
curriculum.
You know,
something I would presume about World
War II and about the terrible situation
and Nazi Germany and the death of 6
million Gypsies and Jews and homosexuals
in the concentration camps in Nazi
Germany.
But my experience with students has been
that none of them know anything about
what happened as a consequence of the
repression of the radical left in the
20th century.
And I believe the reason for that is
that the communist system had extensive
networks of admirers in the west,
especially among intellectuals and still
in fact does,
which is also equally reprehensible.
Um,
and I believe the,
that one of the consequences of that is
that this element of history has been
under,
uh,
what would you say under examined and
certainly very little attention has been
brought to it in a public school
curricula.
And there's absolutely no excuse for
that.
It was the worst thing that happened in
the 20th century.
And that's really saying something
because the 20th century was about as
bad as it gets.
And so,
and the fact that these,
these massive,
these deaths on massive scale occurred
and the fact that we don't know that
deep inside our bones is,
is,
is a testament to the absolute rot of
the education system.
So now you might think this is a strange
thing to discuss in a personality
course,
but I,
I have my reasons for doing it.
That the fundamental reason is that
Solzhenitsyn you might regard as an
existentialist.
Now he says many of this things,
same things that Viktor Frankl says.
Viktor Frankl wrote a book called Man's
search for meaning,
which I would highly recommend.
Um,
and it's a description of,
of the corruption that he saw leading
into the horrors of the Nazi
concentration camp systems,
especially within the concentration
camps itself.
Because Frankl was very interested in
what sort of psychological catastrophe
had to be fall a given individual before
that person was capable of acting as an
agent,
say of the Nazis in the concentration
camp system.
And he concentrated particularly on
these people he called that were known
as trustees within the concentration
camp system,
who were generally Jewish individuals
who are aiding the Nazis in their death
work inside the camps.
Now,
what Frankl did,
because he was also existentially
oriented,
was attempt to draw a parallel between
the individual psychology and the mass
pathologies of the state.
And so the reason that I believe that
this is important in a personality class
is because it's necessary to analyze the
relationship between the psychological
integrity of the individuals with is it
within a society and the propensity of
that society to engage in say,
acts of mass atrocity or to go to go
completely off the rails and then to
engage in acts of mass atrocity.
And so it was Frankel's contention and
also soldier Knutson's contention.
And I would say also the contention of
Vaclav Havel who eventually who was an
author and playwright in Czechoslovakia
and eventually became president,
that the fundamental linkage between the
pathology and the state,
the pathology of the state and the
individual was the individual's
propensity to deceive him or herself and
to,
so to,
to fail.
To Act in an authentic manner,
in a genuine and authentic matter
manner,
and to become as a consequence either
nihilistic,
let's say,
or because because of the incremental
weakening of character that's part and
parcel of,
of adopting an inauthentic motive being
or to turn to ideological and
totalitarian solutions as an alternative
to living appropriately and with
responsibility as an individual.
So soldier Nixon in particular laid at
the feet of the Soviet citizenry,
the burden of the absolute catastrophes
that characterize that system because of
their,
because of the each individual's
propensity or proclivity within the
state to lie and deceive constantly
about what they thought and what they
said.
And to be afraid to speak and to be
afraid to think and to be afraid to
criticize.
And it was no wonder because criticism
of course was at least at at least
became an offense that was punishable by
death.
But these things start much more slowly
than that.
And they start with people abandoning
their,
their own identities and adopting a
pathological group identity.
Well for it,
for any number of reasons.
But one of them certainly is their
desire to shrink for from individual
responsibility and their desire for
ready made ideological solutions.
And so I'm going,
what I'm going to do today is I'm going
to read you a little bit about the Gulag
archipelago and then I'm going to do
show you a sequence of videos about a
recent event that I think does a very
good job of illustrating how this sort
of thing works.
And then I'm going to read you some of
the,
some of what I've code from the Gulag
archipelago so that you get a sense of
what the writing is like.
So soldier knits and basically he,
he committed a huge part of the Gulag
archipelago to memory,
which is really something given that
it's 2100 pages long and printed in like
seven point font and the book is written
at an unbelievable level of emotional
intensity.
It's,
it's,
I remember there was a study once about
how rats respond to cats free living
routes in,
in their burrows.
If they're exposed to a cat or even to
cat odor will run back to their burrow
and stick their nose out and scream for
48 hours.
Right.
Which is about the equivalent of you
screaming for three months because rats
don't,
when we live about two years and well,
that rat is screaming.
All the other rats stay in their burrow
and don't go anywhere and so they scream
ultrasonically so you have to record it
and then slow it down in order to hear
it.
But they're not very happy about that
about cats and they actually don't need
to be exposed to cats to learn how to be
afraid of their older.
They're naturally afraid of it.
Anyways.
Solzhenitsyn's book,
the Gulag Archipelago is like a 2100
page screen.
It's very,
very intense.
It's a very difficult thing to read,
but it's absolutely crucial reading.
It's actually now part of the curriculum
in Russia in high school,
which also says something about Russian
high school as compared to say North
American high schools.
Because I doubt if the typical North
American high school student reads 2100
pages of anything during their entire
education in high school and certainly
not something like the Gulag
archipelago.
So I'm going to read you a little bit of
background about the story.
First of all,
and this is a nice summary.
Um,
I've swiped it from Wikipedia,
but the Gulag archipelago is a book by
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn.
He won a Nobel prize for that,
for the book,
by the way,
and richly deserved at about the Soviet
forced labor camp system.
The three volume book is a narrative
relying on eyewitness testimony and
primary research material as well as the
author's own experiences in a gulag
labor camp written between 1958 and 1968
it was published in the West in 1973
and thereafter circulated in Samizdat or
underground publication form in the
Soviet Union until its appearance in the
Russian literary journal.
Novy Mir in 1989 in which a third of the
work was published over three issues.
So the Samizdat or the underground press
was basically photocopies or,
or,
or sometimes photos,
stats of band works that people would
compile and then hand from person to
person.
Um,
of course the punishment for being
caught with something like that was,
was extraordinarily severe,
but the Samizdat was a,
I suppose it was the precursor to the
Internet.
That's one way of thinking about it.
A slow precursor to the Internet.
Um,
ghoulag or gee,
you lag or ghoulag is an acronym for
the,
for a Russian term,
um,
chief administration of corrective labor
camps,
the bureaucratic name of the governing
board of the Soviet labor camp system.
And by Mytonomy,
that camp system itself,
the word archipelago compares the system
of labor camps spread across the Soviet
Union with a vast chain of islands known
only to those who were fated to visit
them.
Since the dissolution of the Soviet
Union and the formation of the Russian
Federation,
the Gulag Archipelago has been
officially published and included in the
high school program in Russia as
mandatory reading.
Structurally,
the terrace comprises seven sections
divided in most printed volumes into
three parts,
one to two,
three and four and five to seven at one
level,
the Gulag archipelago traces the history
of the system of forced labor camps that
existed in the Soviet Union from 1918 to
1956 starting with Lenin's original
decrees shortly after the October
Revolution,
establishing the legal and practical
framework for a series of camps where
political prisoners and ordinary
criminals would be sentenced to forced
labor.
One of the things that's quite
interesting about the gulag camps,
and this is something that's very
relevant to understanding of modern
Russia,
is that so ordinary criminals were put
into the camps.
And so we're political prisoner
prisoners,
but the ordinary criminals.
And so those would be rapists and
murderers,
let's say,
as well as thieves who were engaged in
theft as an occupation.
Those were regarded by the Soviets as
socially friendly elements.
And the reason for that was that they
assumed that the reason that these
people had turned to crime was because
the pr of the oppressive nature of the
previous czarist slash capitalist
system.
And that the only reason that these
criminals existed was because they had
been oppressed.
They were oppressed victims of that
system.
And so one of the convenient
consequences of that absolutely insane
doctrine was that the Soviets put the
ordinary criminals in charge of the
camps.
And these were very,
very seriously bad people.
And so you can imagine the way that they
treated the political prisoners who were
regarded as socially hostile elements,
sometimes because of their own,
hypothetically traitorous acts,
but more often merely as a consequence
of their racial or ethnic identity,
or the fact that they were related by
birth to say people who had been
successful under the previous system.
So who had any,
any association with nobility or any
association with what were known as the
Kulaks who were the only successful
class of former peasants in the Soviet
Union because they were regarded as
privileged.
You may have heard that word more
recently.
They were regarded as privileged and
therefore as enemies of the state.
And it didn't matter if it was your
father or your grandfather or your great
grandfather who happened to be
privileged,
but the mere fact that you were a member
of that group was sufficient reason to
put you into a camp.
And we're talking hundreds of thousands
or perhaps millions of people who
underwent that fate.
And so the idea and the Soviet Union was
just because you are the member of a
class.
Even as a consequence of your familial
association,
you were immediately sufficiently guilty
to be put into a camp and punished.
And the,
and the terms for the camps were often
10 years,
15 years long.
And if you were very fortunate,
you got to have two or three of those.
So the,
the Soviets really implemented and,
and perfected the idea of class and if
this city based guilt and it's a very
bad road to walk down and it's something
that we're very much engaged in at the
moment because there's discussion
everywhere in North America now about
the idea of while race predicated guilt
for example,
and ethnic predicated guilt.
And it's a very bad idea to classify an
entire group of people as guilty of
anything based on their group
membership.
So these,
these sorts of things are things we
haven't yet learned and certainly should
have.
Now.
The other thing that was very
interesting about the Soviet,
especially about the Gulag archipelago.
See,
it was released in the West in about
1973 or thereabouts now.
The student movement of the 1960s was
very much influenced by Marxist and
communist doctrine.
And that was especially the case in
France where the most reprehensible
intellectuals of the 20th century have
emerged,
including all the damned postmodernists
who've occupied the universities.
Now,
as far as I can tell,
and what happened essentially in France
was that the Marxist slash communist
students were attempting to foment
revolution.
But what happened,
and that peaked in about 1968 and what
happened was,
at least in part as a consequence of
social knutson's revelations,
the idea that the Soviet model or the
mouse model,
for example,
could be used as a,
uh,
an example of the working people's
Utopia was completely and catastrophic
Lee,
and at least in principle,
finally undermined.
Now there had been received because of
the western leftist intellectuals.
All right,
from 1919 forward turned a blind eye to
what was happening in the Soviet Union
now.
And then they were invited there.
Even people,
well people who are,
who are very real,
well regarded in the west were often
invited and who were sympathetic to the
Soviet Union were often invited there
for a visit and the Soviets would do the
same thing in the North Koreans do now
when they invite foreigners to visit,
which,
which is that they would set up fake
places for them to visit called Potemkin
villages where everyone was thriving and
doing well.
That Nazis did the same thing with the
concentration camps to begin with,
especially the ones they established for
children.
And they had,
would invite dimwitted leftist Western
intellectuals to come to the Soviet
Union and see the wonderful paradise
that had been set up for everyone,
which was a complete and your facade and
sham.
And then they would go back to the West
and report on how the utopia was
progressing precisely according to the
Marxist doctorates.
And we knew from the 1930s forward,
cause Malcolm muggeridge did this to
begin with who investigated what was
going on in the Soviet Union,
I think for the Manchester Guardian.
And he started reporting in 19 in the,
in the late 19 tans and then the early
1920s if I remember correctly,
it was approximately in that period,
maybe a bit later,
he recorded what was happening when the
Soviets attempted to collect
collectivize,
the peasant farmers.
And so what they did was take all these
people who were previously pet surfs,
right?
Only a couple of decades previously,
which was not much better than being a
slave.
You're basically property and that was
happening until about 1880 or
thereabouts.
The serfs were emancipated.
Many of them ended up holding their own
land.
Right.
So the land was from the nobles to the
peasantry.
That was something that tolstoy was,
Leo tolstoy was involved in,
and by the time the Soviet revolution
came around,
which would be at the latter part of the
19 teens after the first world war,
the peasant class had actually
established farms,
of course,
varying productivity.
Some of the peasant farmers were very,
very good at being farmers and produced
a huge proportion of Russia's and the
Ukraine's food.
Because one of the things,
we'll talk about this later as the class
progressed is one of the things that
you'll find if the,
if you look at creative production in
any domain,
it doesn't matter.
Artistic Domain,
food production,
novels,
written novels,
sold,
money generated,
number of companies generated,
number of goals,
scored in hockey,
et cetera.
Any number of paintings,
painted,
number of compositions written,
anything like that.
Where where the fundamental underlying
measure is human productivity.
What you find is that a very tiny
percentage of people produce almost all
the output.
It's called a pareto distribution,
and it was studied in detail in
scientific productivity by someone named
Desal,
a price.
It's a square root law.
So here's the law.
Fundamentally,
if you look at the number of people who
are doing,
who are,
who are in a given domain,
who are producing in a given domain,
the square root of the people produce
half the product.
So that means if you have 10 employees,
three of them do half the work,
but if you have 10,000 employees,
a hundred of them do half the work,
right?
It's a very,
very vicious statistic and you won't
learn about that in psychology for
reasons I have no idea about,
because you learn about the normal
distribution and not the prieto
distribution,
but pareto distributions govern,
for example,
the distribution of money,
which is why 1% of the people in the
general population have the overwhelming
amount of money and one 10th of that 1%
has almost all of that,
right?
So I think it's like the richest hundred
people in the world have as much money
as the bottom two and a half billion.
And you think,
well that's a terrible thing.
And perhaps it is.
But what you have to understand is that
that law governs the distribution of
creative production across all creative
domains,
right?
It's something like a natural law.
And we can,
we'll talk about that more,
but imagine what happens when you play
monopoly.
You've all played monopoly.
What happens when you play monopoly?
One person ends up with all the money,
right?
Then you play another game of monopoly.
What happens?
One person ends up with all the money.
It's actually the inevitable consequence
of multiple trades that are conducted
randomly.
So if you take a thousand people and you
get them to play a trading game,
you get each give them $100 say or $10
and they have to trade with another
person by flipping a coin I,
when the coin toss you give me a dollar,
you win,
I give you a dollar.
If we all play that long enough,
one person will end up with all the
money and everyone else will end up with
zero.
So it's a deeply built feature of
systems of creative production and no
one really knows what to do about it
because of course the danger is is that
all the resources get funneled to a tiny
minority of people at the top and a huge
section of the population stacks up at
zero.
But to blame that on the oppressive
nature of a given system is to radically
underestimate the complexity of the
problem.
No one actually knows how to effectively
shovel resources from the minority that
that controls almost everything to the
majority.
That has almost nothing in any
consistent way.
Because as you shovel money down,
it tends to move right back up and it's
a big problem.
Anyways,
the reason I'm telling you about that is
because after the peasants were,
were granted their land and started to
become farmers,
a tiny minority of them became extremely
successful.
And those people produced almost all of
the food for Russia and Ukraine.
So what happened in the 1920s when
bloody lennon came along and
collectivize the farms,
was that they defined the Kulaks who
were these tiny minority of successful
farmers who maybe had a brick house and
were able to hire a couple of people and
had some land and some livestock and
were very productive people.
They defined them as socially unfriendly
elements and they sent groups of
intellectuals out into the towns to
collectivize the farms.
And so the idea was that while you would
pool your land and,
and everyone would farm it collectively
and the land was taken away of course
from the tiny minority of people who are
actually productive and had actually
managed to own much of the land.
So you have to imagine how that would
occur.
Okay.
So it's in the 1920s it's after the
world after World War One rushes in
pretty bad shape.
The villages are full of brutalized men
who have post traumatic stress disorder
and lots of people who are not doing
well at all.
And the bloody intellectuals come into
the town and they say,
you know,
those successful farmers up the street
that you've always been pretty jealous
about in your useless manner while
they're actually pigs and demons who are
stealing from you.
So why don't you come out,
we'll form a nice little mob and we'll
take everything they've got.
And that's exactly what happened.
And all those people were killed or
raped or set off to Siberia in the
middle of the bloody winter where there
wasn't even anything for them to,
to anywhere for them to live or anything
for them to eat.
So they all died.
And then the consequence of that was a
few years later,
6 million people starved to death in the
Ukraine.
And Malcolm Muggeridge had been
reporting on that since the 1930s and so
that was the,
that was the first wind really,
that the west God of exactly what was
happening in the Soviet Union.
But even at that point,
that bloody left wing intellectuals in
North America,
we're so damn clueless and in Europe
that they never paid much attention to
it with,
with the exception of certain number of
people like George Orwell who wrote 1984
and,
and a,
and a animal farm,
which is of course a discussion.
The main pig in animal farm is stallon
of course.
And it's a story,
an allegory about the Russian
revolution,
whose basic motif is,
we're all equal.
But of course some all animals are
equal,
but some are more equal than others.
And that's the motif.
That's the Motif of animal farms.
So there had been warnings all the way
through,
right from the beginning of the Russian
revolution to the West about exactly
what was going on.
But because communists and Marxists
videology is very good at Adlink,
the the week binds of idiot
intellectuals,
there was a huge section of the
population who was fomenting,
I suppose,
against the standard,
what would you call it?
Political,
psychological,
and social order,
who were,
we're absolutely committed to the ethic
that's encased in statements like from
each according to his ability to each
according to his need,
which sounds perfectly wonderful if you
think about it for about 15 seconds.
But if you think about it for six months
becomes unbelievably murderous and it's
reaching and,
and the intent.
And so anyways,
the French,
for whatever reason,
seem to be particularly opaque to
reason.
I'll give you an example.
So the doctrine of Pol Pot in Cambodia
that also killed about 6 million people
hit.
So what they did in Cambodia once the
revolution occurred was decided that
everyone in the city were parasites on
the countryside because the countryside
full of farmers was where the primary
production was taking place and they
regarded the city dwellers as parasites
on that fundamental production.
So they basically emptied out the cities
and up sent all the people in the cities
out to work in the country as forced
labor.
And 6 million people died there.
And the chief architect of that bloody
project got his phd from the Sorbonne
and said exactly what he was going to do
when he went back to Cambodia,
was cheered along by the French
intellectuals who thought that that was
just a fine idea.
So that's all background for why I don't
think any of you guys really know much
about 20th century history.
So anyways,
what happened in the 1970s when when
Solzhenitsyn published the Gulag
archipelago was that it was so
brilliant,
the book and so overwhelming and it's
emotional and intellectual and
historical power that it became
impossible for anyone to continue to
claim that Marxism slash communism had
any intellectual or ethical integrity
whatsoever.
It was done,
it was done.
And that's part of the reason why he won
the Nobel Prize.
And part of the reason,
by the way,
why the Soviet Union collapsed,
because once word got out about exactly
what was actually going on,
there was no way of making a coherent
argument in favor of say,
exporting the Worker's revolution around
the world.
It's like the consequence of that was
well documented by Solzhenitsyn and see
it in the western intellectuals tried to
make excuses for what had happened in
the Soviet Union by blaming it on
Stalins cultive personality perversion
of the original accurate Marxist
doctrines.
So they basically said,
well,
Lennon had Lenin lived cause he died
quite young and was replaced by Stellan.
Had Lenin lived,
the promised utopia would have been
delivered.
But Solzhenitsyn being an absolute
genius documented the relationship
number one b between the axioms of
Marxist and communist thought.
And the laws that were generated
primarily by Lenin and the,
and the construction of these camps and
the d Kulak ization and all the mass
murders.
He documented the causal relationship
between them and laid them clearly at
the feet,
not have stellan but of Lennon.
And so that was also a major blow
because it,
it undermined the remaining argument of
the left way radical left wing
apologists in,
in,
in the West for the,
for the viability of Marxist slash
communist doctrines.
And you still hear people today,
many people when they're faced with the,
you know,
if they're,
if they're Marxist in their orientation
and they're faced with the data
pertaining to what happened in the
Soviet Union,
they'll say something like,
well that wasn't real Marxism,
but one of the things that you might
answer to that is,
well fine,
except that in every bloody country in
the world where that doctrine was
implemented,
new,
regardless of the wide cultural
differences between the culture,
say the Soviet Union,
China,
Cambodia and so forth.
Exactly the same thing happened every
time.
And we still have a great example of
that today in the form of North Korea.
I don't know if you've ever looked at a
map of the world at night.
You know,
you can get a map of the entire globe at
night.
You look at South Korea,
it's lit up like jewels.
It's nothing but light like the east
coast of the United States and Canada
and North Korea is dark.
And the reason for that is that 50 60
years of barbaric communist despotic
rule means a country that's completely
in an industrialized where every single
person is male nourished or starving to
death,
where everyone lives in terror all the
time and where there's nothing but the
continual production of labor in labor
camps just like in the Soviet Union and
Maoist China.
So if we were willing to pay attention,
we could still see examples of that
today.
And that's not an anomaly.
North Korea is exactly what you'd expect
given the doctrines upon which it's
founded.
So,
all right,
so more on the ghoulag.
At one level.
The Gulag archipelago traces the history
of forced labor camps that existed in
the Soviet Union from 1918 to 1956
started with Lenin's original decrees
shortly after the October Revolution
establishing the legal and practical
framework for a series of camps where
political prisoners and ordinary
criminals would be sentenced to forced
labor.
It describes and discusses the waves of
purchase assembling the show trials in
context of the development of the
Greater Gulag system with particular
attention to the legal and bureaucratic
development.
The legal and historical narrative ends
in 1956 the time of Nikita Khrushchev
secret speech at the 20th Party Congress
denouncing Stalin's personality cult,
his power,
and the surveillance that pervaded the
stele and error.
Though the speech was not published in
the USSR for a long time,
it was a break with the most atrocious
practices of the Gulag system.
Solzhenitsyn was aware,
however,
that the outlines of the system had
survived and could be revived and
expanded by future leaders.
Despite the efforts by soldier knits and
and others to confront the legacy of the
ghoulag.
The reality of the camps remained taboo
until the 1980s well crew share of the
Communist Party and the Soviet Union
supporters in the West viewed the
ghoulag is a deviation of the of Stalin
Solzhenitsyn and many among the
opposition tended to view it as a
systematic fault of Soviet political
culture and an inevitable outcome of the
Bolshevik political project.
Parallel to this historical and legal
narrative,
Solzhenitsyn follows the typical course
of a Zack,
a slang term for inmate derived from the
widely used abbreviations zed slash k
four [inaudible].
Zack,
you chenny I guess prisoner through the
Gulag starting with arrest show,
trial and initial internment transport
to the archipelago,
treatment of prisoners in general living
conditions,
slave labor,
gangs and the technical prison camp
system,
camp rebellions and strikes,
the practice of internal exile following
completion of the original prison
sentence and the ultimate but not
guaranteed release of the prisoner along
the ways.
Soldier Knutson's examinations detailed
the trivial and commonplace advance of
an average prisoners of life,
of an average prisoners of light
prisoner's life,
as well as specific and noteworthy
events during the history of the gulag
system,
including revolts and uprising.
Aside from using his experiences as an
inmate at a scientific prison,
Sojun hits and draws the testimony draws
from the testimony of 227 fellow
prisoners,
the firsthand accounts which based the
work.
One chapter of the third volume of the
book is written by a prisoner named
George your gay probably Tenno whose
exploits enraptured soldier knits and to
the extent that he offered to name 10 o
as coauthor of the book,
Tenno declined soldier knits and also
poetically reintroduces his character of
Yvonne Denisovich toward the conclusion
of the book when questioned by the
book's author,
if he has faithfully recounted the story
of the Gulag Denisovich now apparently
freed from the camps replies that you
the author have not even begun the sheer
volume of firsthand testimony in primary
documentation that social knits and
managed to assemble in the Gulag
archipelago made all subsequent Soviet
and kgb attempts to discredit the work
useless.
Much of the impact of the tree ties
stems from the closely detailed stories
of interrogation routines,
prison indignities,
and especially section three camp
massacres,
massacres and inhuman practices.
There had been works about the Soviet
prison camp system before and its
existence had been known to the Western
public since the 1930s however,
never before had the general reading
public been brought face to face with
the horrors of the Gulag.
In this way.
The controversy surrounding this text in
particular was largely due to the way
soldier knits and definitively and
painstakingly laid the theoretical,
legal and practical origins of the Gulag
System at Lennon's feet,
not Stalin's.
According to Solzhenitsyn testimony,
Stalin merely amplified a concentration
camp system that was already in place.
This is significant as many western
intellectuals viewed the Soviet
concentration camp system as a
stalinists aberration,
soldier knits and documented that the
Soviet government could not govern
without the threat of imprisonment and
that Soviet economy depended on the
productivity of the forced labor camps,
especially in so far as the development
and construction of public works and
infrastructure.
We're concerned this put into doubt the
entire moral standing of the Soviet
system in western Europe.
The book eventually contributed strongly
to a need for rethinking of the
historical role of Lennon with the Gulag
Archipelago Lenin's political and
historical legacy became problematic.
Yeah,
problematic and his and the those
factions of western Communist parties
who still based their economic and
political ideology on Lennon.
We're faced with,
we're left with a heavy burden of proof
against them.
George F Kennan,
the influential US diplomat called the
Gulag archipelago,
the most powerful thing,
google indictment of a political regime
ever to be levied in modern times.
The book was published at a time when
many communists in the west.
We're already rethinking their
relationships with the USSR.
As many were deeply disappointed by the
invasion of Czechoslovakia in 1968 in
Germany.
It sparked discussions not only about
Lennon ism but also how to deal with the
memory of World War II.
In an interview with German weekly Zeit
British historian,
Orlando,
Fiji has asserted that many ghoulag
inmates he interviewed for his research
identified so strongly with the book's
contents that they became unable to
distinguish between their own
experiences and what they read.
The Gulag archipelago spoke for a whole
nation and was the voice of those who
had suffered
after the KGB had confiscated a social
knutson's materials in Moscow during
1957 to 1967 the preparatory drafts of
the Gulag archipelago,
we're turning.
It turned into finished manuscripts
sometimes in hiding at his friend's
homes in the Moscow region and
elsewhere.
Well held at the KGB Lubyanka prison in
1945 Solzhenitsyn had befriended Arnold
Susi,
a lawyer and former Estonian minister of
education who had been taken captive
after Soviet Union occupied
Estonia in 1940 Solzhenitsyn entrusted
suzy with the original type and proof
read manuscript of the finish work after
copies had been made of it both on paper
and on Microfilm.
Arnold Susie's daughter,
Heli.
Suzy subsequently kept the master copy
hidden from the KGB in Estonia until the
dissolution of the Soviet Union.
In 1991 the KGB seized one of the only
three extent copies of the texts still
on Soviet soil and the people who held
the copies were unaware of the existence
of the other copies this they achieved
after interrogating Eliza Vata Vora and
scanner one of Solzhenitsyn's trusted
typists who knew where the typed copy
was hidden within days of release by the
KGB,
she hanged herself.
Okay.
The first edition of the work was
published in Russian by the French
publishing house.
Additions destroy a few days after
Christmas,
1973 they had received it go ahead from
Solzhenitsyn,
but had decided to release the work
about 10 days earlier than he had
expected.
News of the nature of the work
immediately caused a stir and
translations into many other languages,
followed within the next few months,
sometimes produced in a race against
time.
American Thomas Whitney produced the
English version.
The English and French translations of
volume one appeared in the spring and
summer of 1974 Solzhenitsyn had wanted
the manuscript to be published in Russia
first,
but knew this was impossible under
conditions then extent the work made a
profound impact internationally.
Not only did it provoke energetic debate
in the West,
a mere six weeks after the work had left
breezy and presses soldier nets and
himself was forced into exile because
possession of the manuscript incurred
the risk of a long prison sentence for
anti-soviet activities.
Solzhenitsyn never worked on the
manuscript in complete form since he was
under constant kgb surveillance.
He worked on only one part of the
manuscript at a time so as not to put
the full book into jeopardy.
If he happened to be arrested for this
reason,
he secretive the various parts of the
work throughout Moscow and the
surrounding countryside in the care of
trusted friends.
Sometimes purportedly visiting them on
the,
on the social calls,
but actually working on the manuscript
in their homes.
Okay.
All right.
So now I want to show you some things.
I haven't done this before,
but we'll see how it goes.
I'm going to show you something that
happened recently.
Some of you may be aware of this and
some of you not.
So this is a video about there was a,
there was a town meeting that a number
of people,
uh,
spoke out,
including one shopkeeper from New York.
And after the meeting he was interviewed
by the PR,
the press,
the TV,
and one of the attendees at the meeting
was upset about the fact that the press
was concentrating on him
instead of concentrating on what she
regarded as the issues at hand.
So I'm going to play this for you to
begin with.
Now what I'm trying to show you,
I want to show you what it means for
someone to be ideologically possessed.
And so you can tell when you're talking
to someone like that,
because this is something I learned from
reading soldier Netsim is because you
can predict absolutely everything
they're going to say.
Once you know the algorithmic
substructure of their political
ideology,
which is usually predicated on about
five or six axioms.
You can use the axioms to automatically
generate speech content.
You don't even have to hear the person.
You can just predict what they're going
to say.
And so that alleviates any
responsibility whatsoever they have for
thinking.
And it also allows them to believe that
they have full control and full
knowledge over the,
not only for controlling,
for,
for all knowledge about the entire
world,
but also the capacity to distinguish
without a moment's thought between those
who are on the side of the good and
those who are not.
And that's where the danger really
comes.
So anyways,
we'll take a look at this.
And
so right now
the news is
a person whose daughter
was a heroin addict.
And I think what he said in his public
comments and he's pro bunker,
he's probably cops.
And so he's the one getting interviewed
and there were like a million people who
have spoken about how they've been,
uh,
abused by the cops,
that they're not being,
they're not being spoken to you.
I don't need the person who's
[inaudible].
He's little set of tasks and congress.
So they got this and that's the one that
they use.
No idea.
We'll find out.
I have a question.
Yeah,
you want my day?
Okay.
Humongous.
Well you mungus humungous well,
I guess humongous.
Humongous mom.
That's what it is.
Humongous.
What is that?
Sexual harassment.
So why did you say that to me?
What?
Humongous walk she might go spoke
humongous wall.
Is that sexual harassment?
Is that what you just did when you said
that to me?
Why?
Why would you say that to me?
Yes,
but my name.
Why would you say that to me?
Why would I say,
why would you say that to me?
What would you ask me?
My name?
Humongous one.
Humongous.
Well,
humongous,
humongous wall
section.
And just just it to me in a sexually
harassing way.
Yeah,
he did.
He said,
do you know what my name is Hugh Mungus.
Awesome.
Just sexually harassed me up.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's right.
Human does wash
pointing to yourself.
You're actually pointing to your body
and you're actually pointing to your
body parts and saying that you're
humongous.
You're actually doing that and this is
the person who just got interviewed and
the probe bunker person of color
represent us using you as a token and
then you speak to me in a sexually
harassing manner.
Defendant Gulf Matta.
Disgusting.
Did you ask him to leave?
Did you ask him?
What is your name?
You want it to this 80 we are hearing.
You need to tell me what your name is.
My name is to know
your name.
What is your name?
What is your full name?
What is your full name and what company
do you want?
Phone
protection.
My name is to know
the wrong person.
He just
asked me
security,
not just happy.
Didn't get the cops.
Get a cop here today.
Why did you do nothing about the
passenger?
Who sexually harassed me?
I made it
back
with a gentleman.
The gentleman gentleman's gone already.
Why are you here?
Why are you still here?
Because we're being really loud and
we're disrupting being loud a crime
for herself.
I understand,
man,
you don't understand anything.
So this got a lot of attention online.
It's just so you know.
And so then she responded because she
was quite intensely criticized.
So here's her response.
Now I want you to listen to how she
speaks.
My name is Anna and I'm doing this video
because we need to talk.
It's become clear to me that a great
deal of us suffer from the illness of
patriarchy.
And it's not just the men who suffer.
Women can be patriarchal too,
really?
But why would they be patriarchal?
Tore to other women?
That's a stupid,
okay.
So many things in our system today come
from patriarchy,
including racism,
colonialism,
capitalism,
classism,
and of course sex.
Yeah.
Wow.
She thinks she knows everything.
Yes.
All these experts with our degrees can
just go home.
One thing to remember though,
it's hard to see something when we're
really close to it.
You have to step back sometimes look at
a system critically to see what others
might be seeing.
I wonder if she's done.
I'm a woman of color,
so I'm going to talk about my experience
that many other marginalized people such
as indigenous peoples and Queer and
transgender people and gender
nonconforming people will have their own
thoughts on this.
Also
indigenous who and what the hell is
gender nonconforming?
What are all these labels?
What is she even talking about?
Why is this woman thinks she can speak
for everyone?
I mean,
who the hell is she anyways?
What a drama queen
challenge is that it is very hard for
those who are marginalized such as women
of color to express how they feel
without being called the angry brown
woman or the angry black woman or the
nagging woman.
Oh crazy.
My God,
she just won't stop talking.
But sometimes I do wonder what women of
color thinking when I make a cross
racial or sexual joke in front of them.
And then I say,
just kidding.
And then afterwards,
why do they always turn me down?
When I asked him to dinner,
it's because of a phenomenon called
white fragility and male fragility.
White liberals and men in general have
been told over and over again,
but if they just never used the n word
and they never talk about race and then
never physically molest anyone and
they're not racist or sexist.
So when I point out that actually the
system of power we live in ensures that
all white people are racist and all men
are sexist because they profit from a
system that marginalizes people of color
and non males.
They attack me just as they've attacked
women of color for centuries to retain
the power structure.
Oh,
she's the sexiest one.
She's the racist more.
Why?
Why does she hate me?
Yeah.
So I make more money because I'm a man
and I have a lot of privilege and my
voice matters at every sphere of life.
But I didn't ask for that.
That doesn't make me racist or sexist.
She talks as if men don't have any
problems.
I haven't had a raise in three years.
I mean,
yeah.
I haven't spoken up for women or done
anything constructive to help women or
people of color and I take my privileges
without question and I live happily in
my own little bubble,
but that doesn't mean that I profit from
their suffering.
It's not my fault.
They're marginalized.
I didn't marginalize them,
so why should I do anything to help
them?
Just because I make more money,
have access to all the education and
resources and housing and jobs.
Recently I was sexually harassed by a
man in public on camera and the new
stations posted the video without my
permission with the question,
do you consider this sexual harassment?
This led to a lot of people attacking me
and going off to me all over social
media.
This is what patriarchy does.
It causes everyone to attack the victim.
The one who is most vulnerable.
This protects the system of power,
which is male sexual dominance.
How do we even know she's telling the
truth about sex or harassment?
I saw that video and the online
reactions from all the men and yeah,
they were threatening rape and violence
and death all while accusing her of
overreacting.
But just because she's putting her
physical safety on the line to talk
about this,
it doesn't mean she's right.
The main complaint that I raised my
voice,
they questioned my sanity because I
spoke up a patriarchal society wants
women to shut up.
Okay.
So now the next thing that happened was
she started a funding campaign to,
to help her out and get her to spread
her message.
So,
okay.
So that,
that was interesting.
And then what happened was this guy here
decided that he was going to start a
funding campaign for humongous.
And so he started a cam,
a funding campaign on a website devoted
to funding such projects and they shut
him down.
So then he started another funding
campaign and he raised $140,000.
And so this is his interview with
humongous,
Oh,
let me turn up my mic,
rudy,
and let's see if that helps you.
Is this better?
Is that better?
Oh yes,
brother.
So you said you were,
you were working this morning blowing
leaves.
Yeah,
so I was,
uh,
in downtown Bellevue and Seattle blowing
what us,
what a salt of the earth man.
Oh,
Jessica pledge $130,000.
And he's out there blown some fucking
leaves.
Y'All can learn something from your boy.
Humongous here.
God Damn,
you don't look,
we got a new president.
But that didn't mean that the leaves
don't need to be still picked up.
Rudy,
how are you feeling right now?
Dude,
I feel loved.
I am really,
truly grateful.
And I mean,
not last weekend I was little trogger
and broke down.
Ready for your eviction.
I'm looking out at the sky and I'm
thinking,
I think I'm kind of screwed today,
you know?
So I took myself down to a church and I
went and prayed.
I went and did confession,
but my confession didn't meet the
criteria at the church.
I swear to God.
What does that mean?
The,
the,
the father stepped out into the
confession room.
She said,
oh no.
He says,
he says,
excuse me,
but uh,
we're going to have to,
uh,
maybe do this aftermath.
And he walked me to the door and I said,
is there a certain way to confess my sin
so maybe I can,
uh,
get it off?
How from seven,
eight,
God,
I mean,
I'm just asking God for help.
And the dude's like,
no,
not here.
We don't want your ass here.
I'd never heard of such a thing.
It's actually really funny.
It's one of those things that make you
go,
Ooh.
And then he went out the front door and
I waited until I got off the church
property and I said,
what that APP was.
So I went up.
So,
you know,
be in your mind as I'm thinking,
I'm hungry after that,
when I see Taco Bell,
yeah,
go over and I've got 75 cents and I'm
thinking,
I wonder if I did a little short on that
one.
And I'm going and I think I'm going to
try another church halfway between the
Mexican restaurant,
Larson's bakery or the church I was
going to,
I get a call from you.
Wow.
Are you serious word of God?
I am not.
I am not kidding.
That same old test and I actually,
incredible.
Hello.
All right.
I remember you said when I called you,
you didn't know it was me and you're
like,
I swear to God,
I'm about to,
I'm having a midlife crisis.
And then you like,
like as if you were speaking to yourself
and then you said,
hey,
who is this?
Do you remember that?
I remember that.
Yeah,
and I hired,
I thought you were somebody else.
Okay.
Yeah.
You said
because that lady is getting funded and
I'm going to fund you because it's not
fair how she's degraded you and I'm
going,
you know I'm going to keep going to that
shirt.
Apparently I'm God's messenger.
What's that?
Am I control the whole time?
God,
God bless him.
Papa.
Bless you.
That's okay.
You're actually ascending to heaven
right now.
It looks like.
I think God is trying to tell us
something right now because the sun,
there's a stairway to heaven coming out
right from the lead top.
Left side.
Oh,
there's the light.
There's a light.
God finally answered your prayers.
I really sure.
How is it that you have and films across
America and around the world?
I really want to,
I can't,
I can't really put it into words other
than that I,
I realized that,
uh,
what I learned from others,
I'm carrying that message of down with
dope up with pope.
I feel like if there was a bible written
today,
I almost feel like that story would be
in their humongous have left the church
and despair walk to Taco Bell with 75
cents in his pocket.
And as he realized he didn't have enough
for a Taco,
he got a ring up,
not from Ethan,
but from the spirit of Papa John who
worked through him and mysterious ways.
Yeah.
You know what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to go drop $300 off to this,
to that churches,
odd shows,
sports program.
Just because [inaudible] a opportunity
to help pull people up and not tear them
down.
No Gate.
Let's date
God.
I want to make it clear that the people
that supported me in this effort
fiscally,
I will not abuse this.
I'm not going to come in and turn it
into some raging drunk that you're going
to see a Frickin padding mine.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh God.
That's,
that's,
that's honestly our worst nightmare.
We're all going to be like,
oh fuck.
Where do we do?
I've already done that stuff when I was
in my twenties I'm 52 I,
there's no way you got to be.
There's,
I mean,
I hope,
well,
we'll be fine.
You on facebook now.
Okay.
We'll be watching the humongous journey
and God bless you all up from this
country and around the world.
I mean,
I'm just absolutely grateful.
Okay,
so this is from the Gulag archipelago.
One of my informants has told me how
executions were carried out at a deck,
a camp on the pitcher river.
They would take the opposition members
with their things out of the camp
compound on prisoner transport at night
and outside the camp pound stood the
small house of the third section,
the condemned man or taken into a room
one at a time and they're the camp get
guards sprang on them.
Their mouths were stuffed with something
soft and their arms were bound with
cords behind their backs and see these
were political prisoners who oppose the
Soviet system,
the condemned man.
Then they were led out into the
courtyard where harnessed carts were
waiting.
The bound prisoners were piled on the
carts from five to seven at a time and
driven off to the Gorkha,
the camp cemetery on arrival.
They were tipped into big pits that had
already been prepared and buried alive,
not out of brutality.
No,
it had been ascertained that when
dragging and them,
it was much easier to cope with living
people then with corpses.
The work went on for many nights at Atac
and that is how are the moral political
unity of our party was achieved.
This is from Viktor Frankl,
from his experiences in the Nazi
concentration camps.
The most ghastly moment of the 24 hours
of camp life was the awakening when at a
still nocturnal hour.
The three shrill blows of a whistle
Taurus pity leslie from are exhausted
sleep and from the longings in our
dreams.
We then began the tussle with our wet
shoes into which we could scarcely force
our feet,
which were swollen and sore with edema
and there were the usual moans and
groans about petty troubles such as the
snapping of wires which replaced shoe
laces.
And one morning I heard someone whom I
knew to be brave and dignified cry like
a child because he finally had to go to
the snowy marching grounds in his bare
feet
as his shoes were too shrunk and for him
to wear in those ghastly moments,
I found a little bit of comfort,
a small piece of bread which I drew out
of my pocket and munched with absorbed
delight
from Solzhenitsyn
in cold lower than 60 degrees below zero
work days were written off.
In other words,
on such days,
the records showed that the workers had
not gone out to work because 60 below
was the cutoff for work,
but they chased them out anyways and
whatever they squeezed out of them on
those days was added to the other days.
Thereby raising the percentages and the
survival medical section wrote off those
who froze to death on such cool days on
some other basis and the ones who were
left who could no longer walk and
restraining every sinew to crawl along
on all fours on the way back to camp,
the convoy simply shot so that they
wouldn't escape before they could come
back to get them.
This is from William Blake.
Oh rose,
thou art sick.
The invisible worm that flies in the
night in the howling storm at found out,
died bad of crimson joy and his dark
secret.
Love does die.
Life Destroy
Solzhenitsyn Mac Beth self
justifications for his murders were
feeble and his conscience devoured him.
Even I ego was a little lamb to the
imagination and spiritual strength of
Shakespeare's evildoers stopped short,
had a dozen corpses.
That was because they add no ideology
ideology.
That is what gives evil doing its long
sought justification and gives the evil
doer that necessary steadfastness and
determination
that is the social theory which helps to
make this act.
His Act seemed good instead of bad in
his own and other's eyes.
That was how the agents of the
inquisition fortified their wills by
invoking Christianity.
The conqueror is a foreign lands by
extolling the grand year of their
motherland,
the colonizers by civilization,
the Nazis by race and the Jacobins early
and late by equality,
brotherhood and the happiness of future
generations.
Without evildoers there would have been
new archipelago,
fire,
fire
branches,
crackle,
and the night wind of late autumn blows
the flame of the bonfire back and forth.
The compound is dark.
I'm alone at the bonfire and I can bring
it still some more carpenter shavings.
The compound here is a privileged one,
so privileged that it is almost as if I
were out in freedom.
This is an island of paradise.
This is the Marfino [inaudible],
a scientific institutes staffed with
prisoners and its most privileged
period.
No one is overseeing me,
calling me to a sale,
chasing me away from the bonfire.
And even then it is chilly in the
penetrating wind,
but she who has already been standing in
the wind for hours,
her arms straight down,
her head drooping,
weeping,
then growing numb and still,
and then again she begs pity.
Asley citizen chief,
please forgive me.
I will do it again.
The wind carries her moan to me just as
if she were moaning next to my ear.
The citizen chief of the gate house
fires up his stove and does not answer.
This was the gate house of the camp next
to us from which workers came into our
compound to lay water pipes into repair.
The old ramshackle seminary building
cross for me beyond the artfully
intertwined many stranded barbed wire
barricade and two steps away from the
gate house beneath the bright lantern
stood the punished girl head hanging the
wind tugging at her gray work skirt,
her feet growing numb from the cold,
a thin scarf over her head.
It had been warm during the day when
they had been digging a ditch on our
territory and another girl slipping down
into a ravine had crawled her way to the
Vladi Keno highway and escaped.
The guard had bungled and Moscow city
buses ran right along the highway.
When they call it on,
it was too late to catch her and they
raised the alarm.
Amine dark major arrived and shouted
that if they failed to catch the girl,
the entire camp would be deprived visits
and parcels for a whole month because of
her escape.
And the woman brigadiers went into a
rage and they were all shouting.
One of them in particular who kept
viciously rolling her eyes.
Oh,
I,
they capture the bitch.
I hope they take scissors and clip,
clip,
take off all her hair in front of the
lineup.
This wasn't something she had thought up
herself.
This was the way they punished women in
the ghoulag.
But the girl who was now standing
outside the gate house in the cold had
sighed and said instead,
at least she can have a good time out in
freedom for all of us.
The jailer overheard what she had said
and she was now being punished.
Everyone else had been taken off to the
camp,
but she had been set outside there to
stand at attention in front of the gate
house.
This had been at 6:00 PM and now it was
11:00 PM
she tried to shift from one foot to
another,
but the guards stuck out his head and
shouted,
stand at attention,
whore or else it will be worse for you,
and now she was not moving.
Only weeping.
Forgive me,
citizen chief,
let me into the camp.
I won't do it anymore,
but even in the camp,
no one was about to say to her,
all right,
idiot,
come on in.
The reason they were keeping her out
there for so long with it,
the next day was Sunday and she would
not be needed for work.
Such a straw,
blonde,
naive,
uneducated slip of a girl.
She'd been imprisoned for some spool of
thread,
but a dangerous thought.
You express their little sister.
They want to teach you a lesson for the
rest of your life.
Fire,
fire.
We fought the war and we looked into the
bonfires to see what kind of victory it
would be.
The wind wafted a glowing husk from the
bonfire
to that flame and new girl.
I promise the whole wide world will read
about you.
Okay.
This is from John Milton from paradise
lost
for wince,
but from the author of all ill could
spring so deep,
a malice to confound the race of mankind
in one route and earth with hell to
mingle and involve done all to spite the
great creator.
I shall despair.
Yeah,
there is no creature loves me and if I
die,
no soul will pity me,
nay.
Wherefore should day since that I myself
find it in myself,
no pity to myself.
That's Shakespeare
soldier knits and describes his
reactions and actions of staunch
Communist Party members imprisoned and
devoured by the system and they support
it and produced frequently.
The camp system vacuumed people up.
Really any concern whatsoever for the
niceties of individual guilt or
innocence.
As far as Stellan and his henchmen were
concerned.
There was probably something that you
were guilty about at some point in your
past and there were no shortage of
people to inform on you regardless of
whether you had done anything.
So one of the things that used to happen
in the collective apartment buildings of
which there were nowhere near enough of,
so multiple families would end up living
in the same tiny apartment,
uh,
was that if you could inform on someone
down the hall who,
you know,
maybe refused to return the quarter cup
of salt you had lent them or something
like that.
If you would inform on them and their
family would be carted away to the
concentration camp system,
then you got to have their apartment.
And so in East Germany at the height of
the Soviet system,
one out of three people,
one out of every three people was a
government informer.
And so that meant if you had a family of
six people,
there were two people in every room that
you were ever in who are ready to say to
the authorities anything you ever had
the temerity to speak and perhaps to
tell them all sorts of things that you
didn't even do because there was a
requirement if you are in former,
to ensure that you had something to say
every time you came into inform.
Well,
it didn't matter if you were a devout
communist,
because from time to time your door
would be kicked down at 3:00 AM in the
morning and people would come in with
Jack boots and get you dressed as
rapidly as they possibly could and take
you away when you were still half awake
to the,
to the prison in the middle of the city
and strip you of your clothes and give
you things that didn't fit and shave
your head and take you off to a camp and
you'd never get to see your family
again.
And that happened to millions of people.
And it happened to staunch communists
just like it happened to people who in
principle,
we're opposed to the system.
And Solzhenitsyn thought that the
staunch communist party members who were
thrown into the camps had the worst time
of edit of everyone because the people
who'd already decided that the system
was corrupt weren't really surprised
when it happened,
even though it was still terrible.
But the Communist Party members had
given their whole life to the system and
then they were picked up just like
everyone else.
And he had a very hard time with them
when they came to prison because most of
them assumed that a terrible mistake had
been made.
And that if they just wrote the right
people,
and con contacted their former friends
who would know,
by the way,
have nothing to do with them,
that the error would be rectified in the
soon would be released.
So they also assumed that everyone else
in the camps was completely guilty and
was there for good reason,
because otherwise the beloved party
wouldn't have put them there.
But for some reason they had been in
prison because they were innocent
despite the fact that they were innocent
and soldiers [inaudible] and his friends
used to play a game with people like
that because he didn't exactly know how
to treat them because on the one hand
they were victims,
certainly.
And um,
but on the other hand,
they were part of the system that had
perpetrated precisely the horrors that
were visited on them.
So when they first came in and were
still chalked full of communist Dogma
and totalitarian thought and judgemental
in every possible way,
him and his friends would have fun
pointing out all the shortages and
catastrophes of the Soviet system and
then let them run through their
algorithmic ideology and until the point
of absurdity and then really not spend
much time communicating with them until
they broke down and decided that things
weren't so good for them or everybody
else.
And more or less entered the common run
of humanity once again
to say that things were hard for them is
to say almost nothing.
They were incapable of assimilating such
a blow,
such a downfall,
and from their own people to from their
only dear party and from all appearances
for nothing at all.
After all,
they'd been guilty of nothing.
As far as the party was concerned,
nothing at all.
It was painful for them to such a degree
that it was considered taboo among them
and comradely task.
What were you in prison for?
The only squeamish generation of
prisoners.
The rest of us with tongues hanging out.
Couldn't wait to tell the story to every
chance newcomer we met and to the whole
cell as if it were an anecdote.
Okay.
Here is the sort of people they were
Olga sleazy,
Oseberg's husband had already been
arrested and they had come to carry out
a search and arrest her too.
The search lasted for hours and she
spent those remaining four hours sorting
out the minutes of the congress of
Staccato vites of the bristle and brush
industry,
of which she had been secretary until
the previous day.
The incomplete state of the minute
troubled her more than her children who
she was now leaving forever.
Even the interrogator conducting the
search could not resist telling her,
come on now,
say farewell to your children.
Here's the sort of people they were
a letter from her 15 year old daughter
came to yell is a veta set cova and the
cows and prison for long term prisoners.
Mama,
tell me,
write to me.
Are you guilty or not?
I hope you weren't guilty because then I
won't join the Komsomol.
So that was the Soviet youth
organization.
I won't join the Komsomol and I won't
forgive them because of you.
But if you are guilty,
I won't write you any more and I will
hate you.
And the mother was stricken by remorse
in her damp grave like cell with it's
dim little lamp.
How could her daughter live without the
[inaudible]?
How could she be permitted to hate
Soviet power?
Better that she should hate me.
And she wrote,
I am guilty.
Enter the Komsomol.
How could it be anything but hard?
It was more than the human heart could
bear to fall beneath the beloved acts
and then have to justify its wisdom.
But that is the price a man pays for.
Interesting.
His God given sole to human dogma.
Even today,
any orthodox communist will affirm that
set Cova acted correctly even today.
They cannot be convinced that it is.
This is precisely the perversion of
small forces that the mother perverted
her daughter and harmed her soul.
Here's the sort of people they were yt
gave sincere testimony against her
husband,
anything to aid the party.
Oh,
how one could pity them if at least now
they had come to comprehend their former
wretchedness.
This whole chapter could have been
written quite differently if today they
had at least forsaken their earlier
views,
but it happened the way Marea Daniel and
had dreamed it would.
If I leave here someday,
I'm going to live as if nothing had
taken place.
Loyalty in our view,
it is just plain pigheadedness.
These devote to the theory of
development,
construed loyalty to that development to
mean renunciation of any personal
development whatsoever.
As Nikolai Adamovich villain,
chuck said,
after serving 17 years,
we believed in the party and we were not
mistaken.
Is this loyalty or pigheadedness?
It was not for show and not out of
hypocrisy that they argued in the cells
in defense of all the government's
actions.
They needed idiot logical arguments in
order in order to hold onto a sense of
their own rightness.
Otherwise insanity.
It was not far off.
I'm going to tell you a story.
It was a story in genesis.
It's the last story in genesis.
It's called the Tower of Babel.
It's a store,
very story,
short story and it occurs after the
story of Noah and the flood
flood stories by the way,
or
universally distributed except among
desert dwellers who have no experience
on which to hang the story.
And Murcia Eliana who wrote a great
series of books called the history of
religious ideas,
documented the,
the uh,
the central narrative structure of flood
stories.
And so what happens is that there's a
human settlement and it's washed away by
a flood.
And the flood is generally envisioned as
a consequence of God's judgment.
And so that the,
if you take the flood stories that are
distributed worldwide and you boil them
down to pull out their architect,
archetypal substructure,
you'll find that there are fundamentally
two reasons that a flood,
oh,
curves and Elliot,
it says that it's the tendency of things
to fall apart,
combined with the proclivity of human
beings to sin.
And so,
so it means something.
This means something.
It's so,
it means that
everything is subject to entropic decay,
right?
Things fall apart of their own accord
across time.
That's why you have to always fix
things.
So if it's complicated,
it has to be maintained.
And so you can think about that in
relationship to say New Orleans before
the hurricane because people say,
well,
the hurricane caused a flood that
destroyed much of New Orleans,
and so that's an act of God.
That's one way of looking at it,
right?
It's a random natural event.
But then you think,
well,
wait a minute.
The Dutch,
their country's mostly underwater,
right?
So they have these huge dykes to keep
the sea back and they build the dike so
that only one storm every 10,000 years
will be of sufficient magnitude to
partially breach the dikes.
That's their engineering tolerance level
one storm in every 10,000 years.
The US Army Corps of Engineers knew that
the dykes in New Orleans were built to
withstand one storm every hundred years,
the biggest storm every hundred years.
And people knew that they weren't built
to proper tolerance and much of the
money that was hypothetically supposed
to be diverted or or,
or an assigned to the rebuilding and
maintenance of the dikes disappeared
because of corruption in New Orleans,
which is in one of the most corrupt
states in the United States.
And so you might say,
well,
why did the flood destroyed New Orleans?
And one answer is,
well,
it was a hurricane.
And the other answer is no,
it was corrupt officials who weren't
paying attention to what they were
supposed to be paying attention to.
And the flood came.
And that's the meaning of the stories
because of the sins of men,
so to speak,
which is the capacity of people to turn
a blind eye to their responsibilities
when they know perfectly well that
something needs to be done.
And so if you don't do what needs to be
done and something comes along to wipe
you out and it's perfectly reasonable to
view that as a judgment on your refusal
to do what you knew to be right.
So that's the flood story.
And then the tower of Babel is a very
interesting story.
It's very,
very short.
And what happens is that it just starts
pretty much abruptly after the flood
story ends.
And it's,
it's a story about the decision that
human beings take to build a mighty
building like a huge,
huge edifice that would reach all the
way up to the heavens to supplant God,
roughly speaking.
And so what happens is that the building
is built higher and higher and higher
and higher.
And God gets annoyed about this and
divides everyone who's building the
building into small groups who speak
different languages,
who then disperse in the construction
project comes to a halt.
Now,
it's a very strange story,
but here's one way of thinking about it.
Larger,
you build a system,
the more there is a proclivity to
worship it as if it's everything.
That's the story of the geology.
Let's you want to build a comprehensive
utopian system that supplants anything
transcended.
You want to build it as large as
possible.
So when it companies encompasses
everyone,
well,
what happens as it grows?
Well,
it incorporates more and more people,
but the people within it become more and
more different from one another.
And so essentially they start speaking
different languages.
And so the entire project of raising
this massive edifice to supplant
everything disperses into chaos and
comes to a halt.
Okay,
so that's one story.
So here's another story.
This is a story that John Milton wrote.
John Milton wrote paradise lost,
which is one of the prime,
okay.
Literary masterpieces of the last
500 years.
Now,
here's what Milton Dick Milton said.
He was trying to justify the ways of God
to man.
That was his purpose.
And so what he was trying to do was take
a look at the world,
the way it's constituted with all its
suffering and malevolence and
corruption,
and to make a case why it was still
acceptable.
And so he did the first,
what you might think about a
psychoanalytic study of malevolence and
evil.
So around the corpus of biblical
writings,
there is an idea of heaven and hell.
And they're not referred too much within
the corpus of biblical writings,
but there are what you might describe as
legends that have compiled around them.
So their,
their stories that never became
canonical.
And those are stories,
for example,
of the idea that God's highest angel,
who was Satan,
Lucifer,
the bringer of light,
the spirit of rationality,
fomented rebellion against God and
Heaven and was passed into hell as a
consequence.
And so there's this idea,
you,
Milton wrote this before,
the rise of the nation states,
for example.
And there's this idea that there's this
idea that there's this tension between
the political and ideological and
rational constructions of the rational
mind and the sort of transcendent
mythology that guides human
organization.
And that Satan as God's highest as the
highest angel in God's heavenly kingdom,
is a personification of the tendency of
the rational mind to produce
totalitarian systems and then to fall in
love with them.
So to produce a system that encompasses
everything like the tower of Babel so
that nothing outside the system is
allowed to exist.
While Milton's intuition,
because he collected the stories about
Satanic rebellion that had been
accumulating across centuries from far
before Christianity was even,
was even constituted,
turned this into a great poetic drama.
And his hypothesis was that the,
the element of the psyche,
let's say the spiritual element of the
psyche that characterize the rational
mind would by its proclivity to produce
these totalizing systems and op itself
into hell.
And so you could think about it as a
prophetic visualization of what was
going to come down the centuries after
Milton wrote because the poet's get
there before the philosophers,
the artists get there.
Maybe before the poets and philosophers
follow in their wake.
The poets are the people who have the
visions of what's coming farthest down
the road.
So this is from Milton.
This is describing Satan after he's cast
into hell because of his rebellion,
his totalitarian,
the consequence of his totalitarian
rationalism.
For now the thought both of lost
happiness and lasting pain torments him
round.
He throws his baleful eyes that
witnessed huge affliction and dismay
mixed with obdurate pride in steadfast
hate as once at once,
as far as angels can.
He views the dismal situation,
waste and wild,
a dungeon,
horrible on all sides,
round as one great furnace.
Flamed yet from those flames,
no light but rather dark lists.
Darkness,
visible served only to discover sites of
whoa regions of sorrow.
Doleful shades where peace and rest can
never dwell.
Hope never comes.
That comes to all but torture without
end still urges and a fiery deluge fed
with ever burning sulfur unconsumed such
place.
Eternal Justice had prepared for those
rebellious here,
their prison ordained in utter darkness
and their portion set as far removed
from God and light of Heaven as from the
center thrice to the utmost pole.
It's an existentialist claim or maybe
it's the existentialist plate
that the
conditions of human life are such that
suffering is an integral part of
existence.
Now it's an important thing to
understand.
It's also a viewpoint shared by the bulk
of the great religious systems of the
world.
Life is suffering.
Why?
Well,
one reason is because of society's
arbitrary judgment,
right?
Every single one of us has
traits and features and and quirks and
idiosyncrasies that are far from ideal
and that are judged by the standards of
society as insufficient.
And so you suffer because of your
imperfect insufficiency in the eyes of
others and you can certainly make the
claim that fairly frequently.
That's arbitrary.
And so that's the claim that society is
tyrannical and judgmental and it needs
to be constantly week constituted so
that the tyrannical element doesn't take
full control and fair enough,
you have to stay awake so that that
doesn't happen.
But the thing is it doesn't matter what
society it is,
although they vary in the degree of
their tyranny.
The mere fact that your group together
with other people and have to come up
with a common value structure in order
to live together means that many of the
things that characterize you are going
to be suboptimal.
And so the price you pay for social
being is that much of you is deemed
insufficient.
Now,
hopefully there are various ways that
you can be within the society that's
sufficiently diverse so that you can
find a place where what's good about you
in the eyes of others and perhaps in
your own eyes can flourish of its own
accord because you don't have to be good
at everything.
If you can be good at at one thing well
enough,
that might allow you your niche and
hopefully a healthy society allow us for
that.
Certainly societies can become so
tyrannical,
but they don't.
So you can lay one source of human
suffering out the feet of tyrannical
social structures.
But the other element of it clearly is
the mere fact of the arbitrary ness of
the natural world.
You have a lifespan that's going to be
counted in the number of decades that
you can count on two hands and that has
nothing to do technically with the
tyranny of the social structure.
Now you could say,
if we got our act together more
completely,
perhaps you could live longer and fair
enough,
but the fact of the limits of your
lifespan and the suffering that's
necessarily a consequence of that,
the death of your parents and the death
of most people that you will know before
you means that that part of suffering is
an integral part of existence itself.
And so that can't be laid at his feet of
an insufficient social structure,
except in so far as it's tyrannical and
blind.
It's a condition of existence.
And then by the same token,
you have your own responsibility for
some of your unnecessary suffering
because there's things you could be
doing to make your life better and to
make life better for other people that
you know perfectly well that you're not
doing.
And so if you stopped doing all the
unnecessary things that make your life
bad,
then it would improve to some degree
that is not ready computable because you
don't know how far you could push that.
So there's three reasons why you suffer
and one is well look at you and the way
you're built.
It's inevitable.
There's not very much of you and there's
a lot of everything else.
And so you just don't last that long and
you're fragile across multiple domains
and then you're harshly treated by
society and there is no doubt about
that.
And then there's responsibility that can
be laid at your own feet.
While the existential take on that in
the thing that all these diverse people
that we've been talking about,
including Viktor Frankl,
including Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn as well
as um,
uh,
Kierkegaard,
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky and the people
that I've already talked to you about is
that the proper pathway through that is
to adopt the mode of
authentic being.
And that is something like refusing to
participate in the lie in deception and
the lie to Orient your speech as much as
you can towards the truth.
And to take responsibility for your own
life and perhaps also for the lives of
other people.
And there's something about that that's
meaningful and responsible and noble,
but also serves to mitigate the very
suffering that produces,
say that nihilism or the flee into the
arms of fleet or,
or the,
or the escape into the arms of
totalitarians to begin with.
You need something to shelter you
against your own vulnerability and you
can adopt a comprehensive description of
reality that's formulated for you by
someone else that neatly divides the
world into those who are innocent and
perhaps innocent victims and those who
are guilty and perhaps the perpetrators
of the suffering.
But none of that has anything to do with
you.
And in addition,
it's simply not,
it's not a reasonable way of assessing
the world that the suffering is built
in.
So that's why the AA,
there's an existentialist insistence
upon that.
So that for the Freud,
Ian's,
the psychoanalysts,
and even for people like Carl Rogers,
to some degree,
if you're in a situation that's
characterized by psychopathology,
if there's something wrong with you,
mentally,
that's a consequence of something gone
wrong.
But that's not the existentialist take
the existentialists take is now.
That's just how it is.
You don't have to necessarily have done
anything wrong for things to get
completely out of control.
It's a terrifying doctrine,
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way
forward.
There is a pathway forward.
Pathway forward is to adopt a mode of
being that has some nobility so that you
can tolerate yourself and perhaps even
have some respect for yourself as
someone who's capable of standing up in
the face of that terrible vulnerability
and suffering.
And that the pathway forward as far as
the existentialists are concerned is by,
well certainly by the avoidance of
deceit,
particularly in language,
but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence in some attempt on your part
to actually rectify them.
And the thing that's so interesting
about that is there were up to,
as far as I'm concerned,
and some of this is from clinical
experience.
You know,
if you take people,
and I've told you this,
and you expose them voluntarily to
things that they are avoiding and are
afraid of,
you know,
that they know they need to overcome in
order to meet their goals,
their self defined goals.
If you can teach people to stand up in
the face of the things they're afraid
of,
they get stronger and you don't know
what the upper limits to that are.
Because you might ask yourself like if
for 10 years,
if you didn't avoid doing what you knew
you needed to do by the death,
by your own definitions,
right within the value structure that
you've created,
to the degree that you've done that,
what would you be like?
Well,
you know,
there are remarkable people who come
into the world from time to time and
there are people who do find out over
decades long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were.
If they said if they spoke their being
forward and they get stronger and
stronger and stronger and we don't know
the limits to that.
We do not know the limits to that.
And so you could say,
well,
in part,
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it.
And of course that's a terrible thing to
admit and it's a terrible thing to
consider,
but there's real promise in it,
right?
Because it means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number,
another way that you could act in the
world.
So what it would reflect back to you,
it'd be much better than what it
reflects back to you now.
And then the second part of that is,
well,
imagine that many people did that
because we've done a lot as human
beings.
We've done a lot of remarkable things.
And I told you already,
I think before the today,
for example,
about 250,000 people will be lifted out
of abject poverty and about 300,000
people a attached to the electrical
power grid or making people were lifting
people out of poverty collectively at a
faster rate that's ever occurred in the
history of humankind by a huge margin.
And that's been going on unbelievably
quickly since the year 2000 the UN had
planned to have poverty between 2000 and
2015 and it was accomplished by 2013 so
there's inequality developing in many
places and you hear lots of political
agitation about that.
But overall the,
the tide is lifting everyone up and
that's a great thing.
And we have no idea how fast we could
multiply that if people got their act
together and really aimed at it.
Because,
you know,
my,
my experience is with people that were
probably running at about 51% of our
capacity.
Something,
I mean,
you can think about this yourself.
I often ask undergraduates how many
hours a day you waste or how many hours
a week you waste.
The classic answer is something like
four to six hours a day,
you know,
inefficient studying,
uh,
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done,
that's probably four hours right there.
Now you think,
well that's 2025 hours a week.
It's a hundred hours a month.
That's two and a half full work weeks.
It's half a year of work weeks per year,
and if your time is worth $20 an hour,
which is a radical underestimate,
it's probably more like 50 if you think
about it in terms of deferred wages,
if you're wasting 20 hours a week,
you're racing $50,000 a year and you are
doing that right now and it's because
you're young wasting $50,000 a year as a
way bigger catastrophe than it would be
for me to waste it because I'm not going
to last nearly as long.
And so if your life isn't everything,
it could be,
you could ask yourself,
well what would happen if you just
stopped wasting the opportunities that
are in front of you?
You'd be who knows how much more
efficient,
10 times more efficient,
20 times more efficient.
That's the burrito distribution.
You have no idea how efficient,
efficient people get.
It's completely,
it's off the charts.
Yeah.
Well and if we all got her act together
collectively and stopped making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time.
Not only do they not do what they should
to make things better,
they actively attempt to make things
worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or or
homicidal or genocidal or all of those
things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package.
If people stopped really,
really trying just to make things worse,
we have no idea how much better they
would get just because of that.
So there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability,
social judgment,
both of which are are,
are,
are major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt.
And that's the thing that's interesting
too is that like one of the,
another thing I've asked often asked my
undergraduate classes is,
you know,
there's this idea that if people have
that people have a conscience
and you know what the conscience is.
It's,
it's this feeling or voice you have in
your head just before you do something
that you know is stupid telling you that
probably you shouldn't do that stupid
thing.
You don't have to listen to it strangely
enough,
but you go ahead and do it anyways.
And then of course exactly what the
conscience told you was going to happen
inevitably happen so that you'll feel
even stupider about it than you would if
it happened by accident.
Because you knew,
you know,
I knew this was going to happen,
I got a warning it was going to happen
and I went and did it anyways.
And the funny thing too is that that
conscience operates within people and we
really don't understand what the hell
that is.
So you might say,
well,
what would happen if you abided by your
conscience for five years or for 10
years?
What sort of position might you be in?
What sort of family might you have,
what sort of relationship might you be
able to forge?
And you can be bloody sure that a
relationship that's forged on the basis
of who you actually are is going to be a
lot stronger and more welcome than one
that's forged on the basis of who you
aren't.
Now,
of course,
that means that the person you're with
has to deal with the full force of you
in all your ability and your
catastrophe.
And that's a very,
very difficult thing to negotiate.
But if you do negotiate it well,
at least you,
you have something,
you have somewhere solid to stand and
you have somewhere to live.
You have a real life and it's a great
basis upon which to bring children into
the world,
for example,
because you can have an actual
relationship with them instead of
torturing them half to death,
which is what happens in a tremendous,
a tremendously large minority of cases.
Well,
it's more than that too because,
and this is what I'll close with,
and this is why I wanted to introduce
Solzhenitsyn's writings to you.
You see,
because it isn't merely that your fate
depends on whether or not you get your
act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being.
It isn't only your fate,
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with.
And so you know,
you think,
well,
there's 9 billion,
7 billion people in the world.
We're going to peak at about 9 billion
by the way,
and then it'll decline rapidly,
but 7 billion people in the world,
and who are you?
You're just one little dust mote among
that 7 billion.
And so it really doesn't matter what you
do or don't do,
but that's simply not the case.
It's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network,
you're a node in a network.
Of course,
that's even more true now that we have
social media.
You'll,
you know,
you'll know a thousand people at least
over the course of your life and they'll
know a thousand people each and that
puts you one person away from 1,000,002
persons away from a billion.
And so that's how you're connected and
the things you do,
they're like dropping a stone in a pond.
The ripples move outward and they affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend.
And it means that the things that you do
and that you don't do are far more
important than you think.
And so if you act that way,
of course the terror of realizing that
is that it actually starts to matter
what you do.
And you might say,
well that's better than living a
meaningless existence.
It's better for it to matter.
But I mean if you really ask yourself,
would you be so sure if you had the
choice?
I can live with no responsibility
whatsoever.
The price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters.
But I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that.
It's not so obvious to me that people
would take the meaningful path.
No.
When you say,
well,
nihilists suffer dreadfully because
there's no meaning in their life and
they still suffer.
Yeah,
but the advantages,
they have no responsibility.
So that's the payoff.
And I actually think that's the
motivation.
Say,
well,
I can't help being nihilistic.
All my belief systems have collapsed.
It's like,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out.
And the price you pay is some
meaningless suffering.
But you can always whine about that and
people will feel sorry for you and you
have the option of taking the pathway of
the martyr.
So that's a pretty good deal.
All things considered,
especially when the,
when the alternative is to bear your
burden properly and to live forthrightly
in the world.
Well,
what's Sojitz and figured out and so
many people in the 20th century,
it's not just him,
even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life,
you pathologize your society.
And if enough people do that,
then it's hell really,
really.
And you can read the Gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude,
fortitude to do that,
and you'll see exactly what hell is
like,
and then you can decide if that's a
place you'd like to visit,
or even more importantly,
if it's a light,
if it's a place you'd like to visit and
take all your family and friends,
because that's what happened in the 20th
century.
[inaudible].